toi c'est quoi c'est l'insécurité dont
il ya plusieurs choses déjà le pouvoir
d'achat c'est vrai que c'est la première
priorité sa survie après il ya
l'insécurité et à l'immigration et c'est
dommage tout ça je voulais fait beaucoup
de sujets qui sont qu'elles sont même
très haut mais moi je vais vous dire un
truc évidemment lié à l'insécurité qui
me concerne mais mais au-delà de ça moi
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir j'ai la chance
d'avoir un père qui étoit militaire qui
m'a fait baigner dans une atmosphère le
patriote pas forcément politisée mais
patriotes et moi quand j'entends
certaines horreurs à longueur de journée
de gens qui n'osent pas dire comme
certains députés la france est soumise
vive la france quand je vois certaines
personnes tire si madame aubenas
abc si elle n'a pas dit je vais rester
alexis corbière dit toujours
amoureux nous déjà vous aimez vous
regardera vidéo des droits de l'homme
ccdh et enverrait ses
excuses et vous monsieur c'est comme si
les avis c'est vrai soit grande gueule
mais rose que vous dites créés dont
celle qu'on passe à autre chose alexis
le rapport merci ou l'agressivité
l'agressivité des gens comme michel
corbière si vous êtes un montant mais
bon il a raison vous savez très bien
qu'il a si vous savez très bien que la
première vous attend jeanne cette ag
est une étude parce que nous sacrifier
vos études bien lui donc voilà je vous
donne un conseil continuez vos nerfs
monsieur pasqua dernier automne
enseignants 2022 c'est fini pour vous
lécher les leurs
vous savez quoi les électeurs qui va
décider si vous allez dire mais voilà
ben va me donner rendez vous en rendez
vous dans dix ans non non non non mais
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez faire l'apologie de crime
et je fais ce que je veux
écoutez moi jeune homme bien élevé bal à
l'ornement techno mais je suis bien
élevé mais je supporte pas le mensonge
il ce n'est pas de sitôt donc vous ne
dites pas que les députés a soumis
n'aime pas vous avez une gamin c'est moi
j'aime la france j'aime les mecs comme
vous je vais karité quête un petit
bourgeois à la maîtrise en
droit de venir assister les députés a
soumis tourné le dos parce qu'on est en
gros
tu
disais tu dis que tu es mons et alexis
corbière existe à nice la céder le nom
mais je voudrais bien au bout c'est beau
jeune homme débarquement non non non non
dits des monceaux nominé
manon et pourquoi son tour sur l'écran
avec l'orgueil sur les grandes gueules
voilà sur les grandes gueules alexis
aujourd'hui expliqué sylvie meyza de
dire vivant vous pouvez laisser parler
les jeunes enjoués serait parce que nous
avons invité non mais c'est ça
il y là il n'a pas parlé pendant que
vous parliez
je reconnais que ça risque car c'est un
jeune bourgeois qui
n'allait pas je ne monte pas en règle
c'est
parfois dur expliqué je m'explique aux
téléspectateurs que je fais passer
danièle obono sur les grandes gueules
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait ça dit cela
c'est daiichi par les romains au lieu de
brailler et
puis la france a fini à 6 min tribune
assise une tribune dans une joie est
grande le nom de justicier est-ce que
vous soyez capable de dire vive la
france elle ne l'a pas dit alors j'ai
dit c'est que c'est vrai les cieux c'est
possible de cette réponse ont crié et
moi vous prenez ça comme en exemple
alors glace et répondent ainsi par ce
mois contrairement à vous j'ai du
respect pour les êtres humains et je
parle pas vendus ils restent beaucoup
moins pour ceux qui avaient de l'argent
mercy on assiste à
la nabo bono a signé une pétition qui
défendent est un artiste qui avait écrit
une chanson qui s'appelle nique la
france mais en tout genre à baisser
jacques s'était dit maintenant on attend
des
[Applaudissements]
champions nous qui sans doute à nos plus
grands poètes français dit la république
moi je la traîne et cetera que vous le
vouliez que l'on aime ou pas il a le
droit de chanter
elle va aux grandes gueules moi j'ai
fait beaucoup les grandes gueules tous
les députés a soumis voyez la couleur de
ma peau c'est pas la même que danièle
obono et jamais on m'a demandé quand je
vais aux grandes gueules de dire
corbières vive la france
c'est ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit moi
j'ai pas de problème et je ne réponds
pas ce genre d'installation vous dire
qu'elle a dit que j'ai demandé à ce que
j'ai à vous dire ce qu'elle a dit que
jacques toi si on le dit vous pouvez
dire vive la france ouais mais non le
journal il je peux dire vive la france
savoir pourquoi en soit je ne relève pas
de matin en disant vive la france voilà
mes tatouages khaled el pais dit elle
peut dire la france
mais vous comprenez monsieur la
différence que c'est humiliant tenté d
une femme député que vous signer une
pétition munichois pour défendre un
artiste et que vous avez quelqu'un et
que vous sous-entendez c'est bon ça
monsieur que je suis moi j'en ai entendu
quelque chose sous-entendez qu'elle ne
veut pas le dire à laquelle elle avait
déjà pas mis à l'essai mais anarchy mais
vous comprenez la du sauna